friday edition of pro football talk p.m
and there's carson wentz
arriving
in indianapolis presumably for his
physical he's allowed to communicate
with the colts he's not a member that
calls until march 17 officially but as a
practical matter he is a cult traded by
the eagles the paperwork goes through in
three weeks and five days
that was the big story from thursday and
it resonates in today because it's
otherwise kind of slow so thank you
eagles and colts for the gift that keeps
on giving thank you peter king for
joining us on this friday edition of
pftp i'm on peacock and siriusxm211
peter what was your first reaction when
you saw that the deal was done because
you and i both kind of come to an
agreement understanding consensus that
there was no rush two days later they
did the deal right
well i think what happened you know if
i'm reading the tea leaves is that
chris ballard was the only fish in the
sea the indianapolis general manager
um
whether he had no offer whatsoever from
the chicago bears or
whether
he had given the bears an opportunity to
make an offer and they
either didn't make one or they were just
sort of
feeling feeling each other out
howie roseman the general manager of the
eagles knew that he only had one
serious contender for the services of
carson wentz
and if i am guessing
um i'm guessing that chris ballard the
general manager of the colts
basically said listen
you know we're not in this forever by
the way you know we we
i i firmly believe they would have been
serious contenders for sam darnold so
i think
basically
howie roseman probably came to his
senses
and he said the realistic selling price
for this player cannot be a rock-solid
first-round draft choice it just can't
be you know you can't expect that the
guy who's the 35th rated quarterback
in the nfl in 2020
out of 36 by the way you can't expect
that that guy
would fetch a first-round pick in return
because nobody knows right now what
carson wentz is this is a leap of faith
trade for the colts
with justification
and this is
we got to get this guy out of here by
the eagles
you mentioned the possibility of the
colts pivoting to sam darnold that would
have been fascinating because it was the
colts and the jets that did the trade
three years ago that allowed the jets to
come up and get sam darnold so there
would have been a nice little symmetry
to darnold ending up with the colts but
i'm with you i think chris ballard
convinced howie roseman this is it
and it's not getting any better in fact
it could get worse in fact it could go
away altogether you better jump now
we're not going to sit here and stare at
you for another three weeks and go
through the motions we have other plans
to make we need to know whether or not
there's going to be 25.4 million in cash
and cap space this year on our books for
carson wentz so we can make our other
plans we've got other players we need to
address whether they're with us or not
with us and we want to put this to bed
and this is what we're offering and
who knows maybe he put
a an articulated specific deadline on
when that offer was going away but
either way they got it done and and
you're right it was always the cults it
was only the cults no one else was going
to jump in unless they thought carson
wentz was going to want to go there and
peter the other angle of this too miles
simmons and i were talking about this
earlier today
when you've got frank reich who knows
carson wentz extremely well from being
the offensive coordinator in
philadelphia you've got somebody who's
in a position
to find out exactly what went wrong last
year and you may not get
the answer with 100 clarity but at least
you get a pretty damn good idea far
better idea than we have on the outside
we just look at it i don't know what the
hell went wrong it just went wrong but
between
wentz's performance
slipping
the issues with the offensive line these
interpersonal problems between doug
peterson and carson wentz adam schefter
pointed out earlier down 97 the fan
fanatic in philly didn't talk for eight
nine or ten weeks how ridiculous is that
but frank wright's in the unique
position to figure out what happened and
to figure out whether or not it was an
aberration clearly they were willing to
bet on it being an aberration and
they're one of the only teams that can
get the full picture at least to this as
close to the full picture as possible
you know the one thing that really
occurs to me
you know after i sat down last night and
analyzed this a bit
mike just think about this for a second
here's what the indianapolis colts have
traded they've traded the 84th pick
in the draft this year
okay and then they've traded either
and look let's just let's guess they've
traded either the
the the 55th or the uh you know
24th
pick next year
and
the colts by the way have a way to
control that if they want to
you know they can they can attempt
anyway it'd be very easy to control this
by the way
if carson wentz misses two or three
games with an injury even if he's
playing well you can find some snaps if
you want to and maybe get them down to
70 percent
uh i'm not saying that they're gonna
they're gonna try to do that but
let's just say it's a one next year
because that's likely what it'd be in
2022.
if you get your long-term starting
quarterback on your cap for the next
four years
at an average of about 24 million
and you pay
the 84th and 25th picks
in the draft for your long-term
quarterback who's still in his 20s
you've made a very good deal now
carson wentz now has to fulfill his end
he's got to be the long-term quarterback
that's the big question
yeah i agree with you completely and
again we we don't know what happened and
we'll only know where it goes from here
the eagles did have confidence that this
was an aberration and it's something
that would fix and look they weren't
exactly selling the guy at a high point
they they were coming off of a very bad
season a very bad relationship they had
to move on and they did move on what
else do you think the colts need to do
now that they know who their quarterback
is going to be
well the colts are in there i believe
their 15th day of draft meetings today
they're setting their draft board you
know as we sit here right now
and
i think what you're gonna see the colts
do right now
is address some of the issues that they
feel they need to address for the long
term okay
and a couple of those things i really
feel like they're going to be cognizant
of their cornerback situation
you know i think they're okay with their
front seven right now but i think they
really feel like they need to address
their cornerback situation and i think
that they would also like to find
another zack ertz type player
and how ironic would it be
if that zach hurts type player
is zach hurts
because i think we all believe that the
eagles most likely
uh because of cap reason some and
because of other reasons too
i think that the colts
uh or i think the eagles at the end of
the day likely are going to part ways
with zach hurts either in a trade or
however but
i think the the other question there is
would frank reich who is along with mike
grow designed the winning play in the
super bowl four years ago this month
carson wentz to zachary's would they
have enough faith if he's out on the
free market to go get him
that is going to be fascinating to me
but that's the other thing
i think
needs a regular security blanket
uh you know sort of a long-term guy but
could they get a quick fix
you know in in in zack or it's you know
they could
and another guy who was let go today by
the eagles desean jackson the last time
we saw him performing at an extremely
high level was week one of the 2019
season when the eagles were down 17-0
against washington deshaun jackson and
carson wentz connected repeatedly a
couple of long touchdowns for deshawn
jackson that sparked the eagles to come
from behind win
they could use a guy who would stretch
the field deep into sean jackson even
though he's been around for a while can
still run he just can't stay healthy but
maybe multiple eagles will be making
their trek to
indianapolis from philly as the colts
try to get over the hump they're in the
conversation the question is how far
will they take it with carson wentz and
when you look at what they're going to
spend and when you look at where the
market currently is if they keep them
for all four years it's right around 100
million dollars for four years that's 25
million a year that's nothing that's
nothing now that's 20 million below the
top of the market in patrick mahomes so
this is a great deal and they're only
really tied in for two years because
next year's 22 million dollar payout has
15 million fully guaranteed as of march
19th
so you're in for two years and then you
can keep him for the final two at 51
million which really isn't all that much
it won't be all that much two years from
now and if they really like what he's
done the first two years i wouldn't be
surprised if they rip up those last two
years and give him a new deal if they
are
where they hope they'll be now that
they've completed they hope
this process from andrew luck to jacoby
brissette to philip rivers to carson
wentz
you know what is really amazing and you
just said it might i mean think about
think about how much money
they have spent on quarterbacks i mean
you go back to
2018
um and
you know obviously 2018 you've got
you've got a full year of uh you know
you andrew lucky is your guy in the
future and then 2019 until late august
that saturday night you realize that oh
my gosh we got to find another
quarterback but you remember
jimmy irsay did not make ander luck pay
back the 12 million dollars in bonuses
that he got in 2019 so
you've got ander luck uh with 12 million
you've got uh you know jacoby brissette
with
i what was it like 17 million or
whatever it was
but you pay your quarterbacks 31 32
million because you also had brian hoyer
in 2019
and then in 2020 you get phillip rivers
and you're still paying jacoby brissette
so you're well over 30 million again in
2020 and now this year
you know i guess you're gonna be
wence eason
and likely
one veteran
cast off somewhere
uh i doubt it would be a fits magic type
guy but you know some veteran guy at
three or four million you're going to be
over 30 million again and you know deep
down you're not positive that you got
the long-term guy
so
you know the colts have made an awful
lot of major investments in at the
quarterback position
it's interesting to see if they finally
got the one who they want
long term this year
and peter they better have someone they
feel good about is the back up to carson
wentz because he has an extended injury
history so
i don't know that eason is enough and i
doubt that they'd bring nick foles to
indianapolis although that would make
for one hell of a story if once and
foles were back together again with
frank reich as the head coach but
they've got to have somebody they've got
to have somebody i think that's one of
the reasons why that threshold's in
there that playing time threshold it's
not just the possibility he gets benched
it's the possibility he physically can't
complete the season that keeps that pick
at a second rounder for the indianapolis
colts and speaking of second
quarterbacks jalen hurts may still be
the second quarterback in philadelphia
all we know is the eagles highly value
their number two quarterback whoever it
is my understanding they view it as a
top 15 roster position so
there's already the talk that they're
going to bring in competition for hertz
the only thing we don't know at this
point will there be a veteran will there
be a draft pick i still think it makes
sense to have someone order since jalen
hurts is so new to the game but they're
sitting there with the sixth overall
pick you never know who's going to be
there you have to be ready for the
possibility that maybe you get somebody
who becomes the the guy that carson
wentz was supposed to be
mike the most sensible guy for the
philadelphia eagles is jacoby brissette
i mean you know basically you have the
guy who's coached him daily
uh in the last couple of years obviously
nick ciriani
and you know
he would come in knowing that hey look
the job is the job absolutely belongs to
jalen hurts but you never know
um and and look i totally agree with you
i do not put it past them
i will not be surprised
if they draft a quarterback uh at number
six overall it was really interesting
and you know i'm just starting this week
to kind of dive into
i i know nothing about college football
i don't really follow it very closely so
i just get into it after the season so i
start listening to podcasts and then
watching some stuff on youtube some
highlights
and it amazes me that that basically
there is some consternation over how
these top four quarterbacks are going to
fall and whether mac jones belongs in
that discussion at alabama so
i really believe right now that
you know you've got you've got todd
mcshade this week on their podcast at
espn saying basically zack wilson is the
no doubt number two to trevor lawrence
and you know so we're gonna have about
you know two and a half more months of
that to put up with mike but in general
i think that philadelphia you definitely
cannot count them out of a quarterback
at number six
and jacob bersett i feel like never got
a full chance in indianapolis he was
having a surprisingly good year if i
recall correctly and there's a chance i
don't they were five and two at one
point he suffered a knee injury and then
was never really the same guy after the
mcl strain that knocked him out for a
couple of games
and and then he's just cast aside for
philip rivers so that that would be a
guy who could make some sense to
to compliment jalen hurts and we really
don't know much about jalen hurts he
started four games got yanked from what
could have been an exciting moment
against a washington team that may have
knocked them out of
playoff contention would have knocked
them out of playoff contention you know
and the thing about a young quarterback
any quarterback you need four five six
games of film before you know what he's
all about there's a chance there's going
to be a ceiling that jalen hurts hits in
2021 that he may not be able to bust
through we just don't we don't know
enough about him at this point
and the other thing you can't i mean how
ironic it would be if it were jacoby
brissette but
it'd be about 18 times more ironic if it
was nick foles
and you know you really mike
no one knows what's going to happen to
nick foles in chicago we're assuming
that mitchell trubisky becomes
i don't know deep in the back of my mind
i kind of think san francisco but i
really don't know nobody knows
but i i i'm looking at chicago as really
tabula rasa as an absolute blank slate
when it comes to the quarterback
position you know could they wait and
draft somebody who knows they're down in
the draft at number 20.
um would they be willing to
trade up and really risk the future
without the gm and coach knowing if
they're really going to be there long
term
that's why the run-up to this draft i
think is going to be so much fun because
even though we're getting a lot of
answers at the quarterback position
it's almost like every answer
creates a new question
because you think okay philadelphia you
know
jalen hurts now okay
but they're not they're they're probably
gonna add two if if if not more so
and they got all the cap problems so
all of these things to me are very very
interesting when you look at both the
short and long term of both the
philadelphia eagles and the indianapolis
colts
you mentioned the bears and the fact
that the gm and the head coach there
ryan pace matineggy respectively under a
certain amount of pressure to get this
right howie roseman the gm in
philadelphia is under pressure too doug
peterson's gone howie roseman manages to
survive
and now they've got this play where they
decide to move on from carson wentz and
if wence plays extremely well for the
colts do you think the people in
philadelphia are going to say we
understand why you traded him if once
becomes the guy he was in 2017 they're
going to be hearing it louder than ever
that you idiots didn't see that this is
the guy you should have kept what are
you doing with jalen hurts and if we
just would have rallied around carson
wentz he'd be our guy now we got to see
him thrive in indianapolis so they got
the double whammy here they got to
figure out their own deal at quarterback
they got a hope at some level that wentz
doesn't become mvp
finalist
and above all else they just got to win
some football games i've been saying
this for weeks now i think those eagles
fans the worst thing that could have
happened was them winning a super bowl
because they are like addicted to it now
and they want it and if this team is in
rebuilding mode they're going to be even
more pissed off than they were last year
peter
mike what's what is absolutely amazing
is and and it's not
it's not that really
uh utterly shocking necessarily but
think of how amazing it is
that your team wins the super bowl 48
months ago
the head coach is gone
the quarterback is gone the super bowl
mvp hero of the super bowl run
he's gone he's gone he's back he's gone
um and
your offensive coordinator he's gone
your defensive coordinator he's gone
your best weapon for the quarterback
i would say is likely gone you know in
zach hurts and and just just think about
this you know your big weapon in the
running game
legarrette blount he's long gone you
know had a big super bowl so all of
these things just in the space of four
years in space of four years
your franchise is basically brand new as
a matter of fact i was looking at it the
other day mike think about this
the only huge player in that game
assuming zach hurts is gone the only
huge player in that game who's still
there
is brandon graham he's the guy who got
the strip sack on brady who basically
ended the patriots last gasp in that
game it was really funny by the way just
as a total aside when i went on my
training camp trip the next year
uh brandon graham has that video
on his phone
of him strip sacking tom brady and he
said i watch it every day
and i bet he still does by the way but
imagine brandon graham
you know who's not a superstar he's a
very good nfl player but he's still
there and virtually everybody else who
is valuable in that run is gone
i'd have to do the research to come to a
firm conclusion on it i can't imagine a
super bowl team that has fallen apart
faster than the e
they've just been absolutely dismantled
and it felt like they it always feels
like the super bowl winners got staying
power it always feels like it but one
thing led to another and the eagles a
far different team they were i'm going
to skip forward to a question from
ricardo hines on twitter we put out a
call for mailbag questions we're going
to sprinkle a couple of them in now
because they're relevant to the topic
who was more responsible for philly's
run in
2017. was it frank reich and his work
with the quarterbacks or was it doug
peterson in his work as the head coach
i think it was doug peterson because the
buck stopped with doug peterson yes
the story i just told you in the story i
wrote in a very
3500 wordish way
eight days after that super bowl win
over new england about the winning play
frank reich might grow the receivers
coach and doug peterson basically
mike grow harvested this play
you know he brought it to frank reich
and wright said this is brilliant we got
to use it so then they go to doug
peterson and remember they still have to
sell doug peterson
and so he says yeah i love this this
play was harvested by the way
in minneapolis once the eagles got to
their hotel the radisson uh in in
minneapolis and so they didn't even put
this play in the winning play to zach
ertz until the week of the game
so what i'm saying is that
the brain power of frank reich and his
staff was great but
remember also doug peterson is the guy
who also has has to say
when uh nick foles comes to the
sidelines and says philly philly doug
peterson's got to be the one who says
hey let's run philly special and you
know the rest is history but i guess
what i'm saying mike is is in my opinion
especially with the guts that doug
peterson had down the stretch in so many
ways on so many play calls i think
you've got to give the the vote to
peterson
i mentioned earlier that adam schefter
said on 97 the fan and fanatic the 97
the fanatic in philly earlier today too
many phillies too many fanatics in that
sentence to get it out properly that
carson wentz and doug peterson didn't
speak for eight nine or ten weeks that's
inconceivable to me not in the princess
broadway in the real way
how inconceivable how in the world can
the starting quarterback and the head
coach not speak
for eight nine or ten weeks now once was
benched for the final four i doubt there
was a lot of conversation between
peterson and wentz then
but i i i don't know i there has to be
some hyperbole in it i found a photo
of peterson and wentz standing next to
each other on the sideline of the game
on november 30. i doubt they just chose
to stand in the same place and not
communicate so i don't know if that
meant beyond the games beyond the locker
room beyond wherever but regardless of
where that set in wherever that cold
shoulder was happening you can't have
that in any functional workplace where
two of the most important employees
simply don't communicate
and how does that not stick to doug
peterson remember we heard all about
emotional intelligence when chip kelly
was fired and doug peterson was hired
there's not a lot of emotional
intelligence rattling around a situation
where you don't talk to the quarterback
and the quarterback doesn't talk to you
mike i mean but i really think this has
to go both ways
um
you know we have talked about this i
have written this i'm sure we've talked
about it sometime in the last month
on on the show
and that is that the stories going
around
internally in philadelphia
are a
carson wentz had become a very hard guy
to coach he did not take coaching well
b
he was angry
that
jay
jalen hurts was drafted
because he felt like it showed a lack of
faith in him where
look
we could discuss this for six hours
uh and we're definitely not going to
discuss it for more than six seconds but
essentially
howie roseman and this organization
view the backup quarterback with all of
the flurry of activity at the
quarterback position in the last four
years they view the backup quarterback
as a top 10
most important position
on our team
why wouldn't you backstop it with
somebody better than nate sutfield
and i think thirdly thirdly
you know
there comes a time
when a guy is not receptive to coaching
when he gets bitter it's sort of the
little things there comes a time
where you know that he's mentally shut
off
that's where he was now
i'll always be interested to know if
when they interviewed nick ceriani and
josh mcdaniels you know one who got the
job one who didn't at the end
i'd like to know
did they tell them we're trading this
guy or did they tell him we're up in the
air on this guy because honestly don't
you think that would have have had a
little something to do with the decision
of of one or both of those guys about
taking the job i mean
you know four years ago carson wentz was
a top 10 maybe top five nfl quarterback
and so this is all you know this is
going to be really interesting
book writing about five or ten years
from now when we start to get the
answers to some of these questions
and peter i think carson wentz is not
going to fare very well when the story
is told i i'm trying to get the benefit
of the doubt because we don't know the
story but i hear the way you're saying
it and and it meshes with what we've
heard and it's like what has he done to
deserve
this attitude absolutely
to justify being being uh you know
entitled and needy and and and and
shattered by the fact that a second
round pick was spent on a quarterback
god forbid look at what it did to tom
brady when they used the second round
pick on jimmy garoppolo it propelled
this second half of his career that has
seen him win four more super bowls look
at what it did there
when they drafted a quarterback in round
one maybe this was a test to see what
they really had in carson wentz and they
found out that wence didn't pass it
look
we don't know all of these things carson
wentz has been a sphynx for the last
couple of months so we just don't know
but
uh the story that is being told
basically
is that he thought that he was quite
entitled
and it doesn't really ring right
with the guy who
uh you know has always been an
incredible worker bee and all that stuff
and that's why it's gonna take a lot
more reporting to find out everything
that happened here
but to me
it just doesn't seem right you know as
bucky brooks has said from nfl.com
being a starting quarterback in the nfl
is not a lifetime appointment carson
wentz felt it was and as i mentioned
earlier the fact that frank reich is in
position to harvest the information and
come to a reliable conclusion he could
write the story if he wanted to about a
lot of the stuff that went on he knows
he believes he trusts that carson wentz
is going to turn it back around one last
question before we move on to other
topics this is a question from our good
friend a red zone alk
who's under more pressure in 2021 rams
gm less sneed or eagles gm howie roseman
both guys shedding contracts that in
hindsight they should not have entered
into
with top two quarterbacks from the 2016
draft
definitely howie roseman because howie
roseman made this deal
and
yeah obviously les sneed
made the deal in los angeles
but
sean mcvay was the motor behind that
trade there's a lot more pressure in my
opinion on sean mcvay than there is on
les sneed
if and i don't believe he will fail
but if uh you know if
if you go and make a huge trade and you
get matthew stafford on your team
and you are basically saying okay we're
giving away two ones for this guy
i mean he's got to work out and it's
yeah it's less sneed maybe he was a
little too generous on the trade we'll
find out
but honestly mike look at it who
propelled that trade who made that trade
to happen that was not less sneed that
was the head coach of that team whereas
in philadelphia
nick ciriani just got there 10 minutes
ago he's just a pawn in this if they
give him carson wentz he's going to
coach him if they give him jalen hurts
he's going to coach him so this is a
howie roseman deal in philadelphia
yeah i agree with you completely les
snead has been with the rams since 2012
largely as a table setter with the gm
title but it was jeff fisher that was in
charge and now it is as a practical
matter sean mcveigh who's in charge even
though mcveigh's not the type of guy
who's going to walk around and say i'm
in charge the reality is he gets the
players he wants he wanted stafford and
more importantly he wanted goff gone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports